اذا في الوقت الذي تتجه فيه الانظار الى
تركيا طبعا قبيله الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في نهايه الاسبوع يحشد
اردوغان انصره على امل تجاوز الاختبار
الاهم في مسيرته السياسيه تظهر احدث
استطلاعات الراي ان كمالك كليتش طبعا هو
منافس اردوغان اللدود يتقدم عليه مستغلا
ازمه غلاء المعيشه الناجمه عن التضخم
اضافه الى طريقه التعامل مع الزلزال
المدمر كما انه يتقدم مستغلا السجال الذي
اثير مؤخرا حول توجهات الناخبين الشباب
الذين يمثلون خمسه ملايين ناخب وان نسبه
كبيره من هؤلاء الناخبين الجدد تعارض نظام
الحكم الذي ينتهجه اردوغان تتحضر المعارضه
لالغاء الكثير من السياسات التي اتسم بها
حكم اردوغان حاله ما فازت المعارضه تعهدت
باعاده الاستقلال للبنك المركزي وايضا
الغاء سياسات اردوغان الاقتصاديه غير
التقليديه المعارضه تعتزم ايضا للنظام
البرلماني السابق فضلا عن ارسال اللاجئين
السوريين الى بلدهم كما تهدف الاحزاب الى
تحسين العلاقات مع الحلفاء الغربيين بما
في ذلك الولايات المتحده ستظل كيفيه حشد
المعارضه لتاييد الاكراد الذين يمثلون 15%
من الناخبين نقطه مفصليه فبالرغم من ان
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي المؤيد للاكراد ليس
جزءا من تحالف المعارضه الا انه يعارض
اردوغان بعد حمله قمع استهدفت اعضائه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات